thanks for having me Sam I'm Stanley I'm
the founder of door - and it's it's
really amazing to be here because it
wasn't naturally that long ago where I
sat in in your seats I was class of 2014
graduated in CS as well as my co-founder
Andy and for those of you who don't know
what doordash is we're building an
on-demand delivery network for local
cities and I want to start off with this
photo that I took just a few months ago
and I think if this was a night when we
just raised our Series A and I took this
photo as I was walking back to where I
lived actually living Robley at the time
on campus and I took this photo because
I realized this how ridiculous the
combinations of things I was holding in
my hand at the time you know I was
holding my CS 247 homework and then I
had a my tax forms since so it was April
and had to fill out taxes and then also
that yellow speeding ticket and then
right below that was the was a fifteen
million dollar piece of paper I just
signed from Sequoia and that kind of
summarizes just how ridiculous our
journey has been you know starting at
Stanford doing this while I was at
Stanford and then transitioning this
into an actual startup and I want to
share that story with you today
it all began two years ago actually in a
macaron store it was my junior year at
Stanford
this was Fall Quarter and at the time I
was really passionate about you know how
do you build technology for small
business owners and I sat down Chloe the
owner of you know Shawntel G on that
canoe store in Palo Alto at the time
just interviewing her you know trying to
get feedback on this on this product
prototype we've been working on and also
just learning about you know what her
problems were in general and it was
during this meeting when Chloe first
brought up this problem of of delivery
you know she I remember she took out
this really really thick booklet and she
showed me pages and pages of delivery
orders and a lot of these orders she had
to turn
because there's no way she could have
fulfilled them you know she had no
drivers and she was the one who ended up
having to personally deliver all these
orders and and that was a very
interesting moment for us and and then
we thought the next over the next course
of over the course of the next few weeks
we talked to you know around another 150
200 small business owners and when we
brought this idea of delivery they kept
you know they kept you know agreeing
with us saying yeah this is this is a
really big problem for us you know we
don't have you know delivery
infrastructure is such a huge pain for
us there's there's not any good
solutions out there and which which let
us wonder you know delivery such a
common thing it's such an obvious thing
why hasn't anyone solved this before
right like we must be missing something
here so we thought maybe maybe because
people have tried this in the past right
but they failed because there wasn't
consumer demand for this so we thought
okay how can we test this hypothesis you
know we were just a bunch of college
kids at the time you know we didn't own
trucks or delivery infrastructures or
anything like that right we can't just
we can just spin up a delivery company
overnight so how can we test this
assumption we had so we decided to
create a simple experiment with
restaurant delivery we spent about an
afternoon just putting together a really
quick landing page and you know I went
on the internet I found some PDF menus
of you know restaurants in Palo Alto
stuck it up there and then had a phone
number at the bottom and which was our
personal cell phone number actually and
that was it we put up the landing page
we called it Paul to delivery comm and
this is actually what it looked like you
know super super you know simple ugly
like honestly we we weren't really
expecting anything we just launched it
and all we wanted to see was you know
would we get phone calls from this and
if we got in the phone calls then that
maybe this was this delivery idea was
something worth pursuing so we put it up
there we weren't really expecting
anything and we were driving back home
and
all of a sudden we gotta got a phone
call you know someone called they wanted
to order Thai food and we're like oh wow
this is this is a real order like you
know we could have to do something about
it right so so we're in our cars and and
we're like okay like we're not doing
anything right now Nazli just lets just
stream by you know Siam Royale pick up
some Pad Thai and it's delivered to this
person and let's try to learn how this
whole delivery thing works and we did we
delivered to this guy and up in Alpine
Road I remember he he told us he was a
asking me oh how did you hear about us
you know
what'd he do he told us he was a he was
a scholar and then he handed me his
business card and I said he was the
author of a book called weed the people
and that was like our first-ever
delivery right it was it was like the
best of the first delivery slash worst
delivery you could have asked for we
couldn't make this stuff up and and and
yeah and then the next day we got you
know two more phone calls that day after
that we got five and then it became 7
and then became 10 and then soon we
started gaining traction on campus with
Powell to delivery comm which was which
is um which is pretty crazy because
think about it right this was a landing
page you have to look up PDF menus to
place your order and they have to call
in this isn't exactly the most
professional looking site yet people
were still we stepped we kept getting
phone calls we kept any orders and and
that's kind of when we knew we were on
to something when people are willing
like we knew we found this need people
wanted when people are willing to put up
with all this so I think another key
point to remember is that we launched
this in about an hour right like we
didn't spend you know we don't have any
drivers we don't have any algorithms we
didn't spend you know we have a back-end
we didn't spend six months building like
a fancy dispatch system and we don't
have any of that we just launched
because at the beginning none of that is
necessary right at the beginning is all
about test
your idea trying to get this thing off
the ground and figuring out whether this
was something people even wanted and
it's okay to to hack things together at
the beginning at YC there's a mantra we
we like to talk about is doing things
that don't scale so at the beginning we
were the delivery drivers you know we
would you know go to class and then
after class we'll go you know deliver
food we were the you know customer
support like I sometimes have to take
phone calls during lectures we we had to
we spent afternoons just going down
University Avenue passing out flyers
about kind of promoted or - I mean we
didn't have any dispatch system so what
we had to do was you know we use square
to charge all of our customers we used
Google Docs to keep track of our orders
we use apples find my friends to keep
track of where all our drivers were you
know stuff like that I'm just thinking
out like what's just hacking together
solutions you're trying to get this
thing off the ground in fact at one
point we were growing so fast that
Square actually shut our countdown
because we were under suspicion for
money laundering I mean think about it
we're getting small chunks of like 15
$20 orders coming in at a rapid pace
it was yeah and luckily my co-founder
Tony worked at square so he just emailed
somebody's there and everything was
solved yeah
and another thing about doing things
that don't scale is that it also allows
you to become an expert in your business
right like driving helped us understand
how the whole delivery process worked
you know we use that as an opportunity
to talk to our customers talk to our
restaurants we the dispatching which
helped us figure out you know how we
manually dispatched every driver and
that helped us figure out you know what
our driver assignment algorithm should
look like we did customer support
ourselves you know getting real-time
feedback from from a customers I
remember you know for the first few
months when we got started we would
manually email everything
one of our new customers and at the end
of every night and just asking them oh
how was your first delivery how did he
hear about this and we would personalize
all these emails right like if I see
someone order chicken skewers from
orange hummus I would say oh like I love
orange Thomas you know how our chicken
skewers how did how did your first
delivery went you know just feedback
like that was was really valuable and I
customers really really appreciated that
and and I remember um one time this was
during YC we were at a we just came out
of meeting with one of our restaurant
partners and you know we wanted we heard
about this ice cream store that just
opened up you know on University Avenue
called cream and we wanted to go try it
out and then all of a sudden our
co-founder back at our you know office
flash house texted us saying oh we need
drivers on the road we got a huge spike
in demand so we debated for maybe you
know 10 seconds like should we go get
ice cream or should we go go deliver
obviously we went and delivered but that
kind of became our motivation on you
know scaling right like if we can scale
then we could go get ice cream next time
so so yeah I think that kind of and now
of course we've scaled across different
cities now you have to worry about
building out automated solutions and
dispatch systems and figuring out how do
you match demand and supply and all that
fancy technology stuff but none of that
matters at the beginning because at the
beginning it's all about getting this
thing off the ground and trying to find
product market fit so just to summarize
so there's three things I would say that
I learned from from doing door Dash's
first test your hypothesis you want to
treat your startup ideas like
experiments the second thing is launch
fast we launched in you know less than
an hour with a really simple landing
page and finally it's okay to do things
that don't scale doing things that don't
scale is one of your biggest competitive
advantages when you're starting out
and you can figure out how to scale once
you have the demand and maybe once
you've scaled then you go get that ice
cream thanks yeah question was how did
our first customer hear about us
our very first one I had no idea we just
launched pop Paulette of delivery calm
we don't do any marketing so I assumed
he just must have typed in politic
delivery into the web browser and then
after that we didn't do it did barely
any marketing I think I sent out like
one email to my dorm and does about it
it was all through word-of-mouth and and
that kind of just validates you know
just how strong the needy found you know
when people just start talking about you
and they're willing to put up with all
this you know terrible user experience
terrible design and stuff like that
it seems so obviously you're wondering
why no one's done this what's your
answer now yeah I mean looking back I
think I think the biggest thing is
mobile the fact that now everyone has
one of those in their pocket and we kind
of saw that trend and and thought you
know what if you can design you know a
delivery system that was entirely based
off mobile you know where you don't have
it you didn't have to have to have any
infrastructure or delivery fleets
instead you could you know instead of
hiring drivers full-time purchasing
vehicles what if you can tap into a more
of an on-demand pool of independent
contractors and I only send orders to
them when when they have time so so
that's kind of the the insight we had we
everything was done through mobile yeah
yeah I mean at the time we just wanted
we're all really passionate about
building technology for small business
owners and and honestly this delivery
thing came out of a experiment right
with the landing page like it was
literally an experiment we didn't we
weren't expecting anything and it just
took off and and we went with it
and logistics was always something we
were really passionate about as well you
know like the logistics transportation
and it's kind of the perfect fusion of
you know how do you help small business
owners through delivery back yeah do you
launch at first or the website and how
long did it take from idea to the first
launch yeah it was we started with this
landing page right here took us an hour
to launch yeah the question was how does
the or - Daniel am on a very competitive
space I mean I mean in the beginning I
mean for us consumer demand has never
been the problem
you went up until now so for us it's
just about you know finding a need and
just focusing on serving that serving
that demand so I mean the beginning
competition doesn't really matter when
you're getting started yeah question was
how long it took for us in corporate
into a company when we went through YC
so we launched in January 2013 and then
we did YC that very summer and we when
we decided to take this idea through YC
we incorporated one more yeah you what
do you plan to do next or where do you
plan to go with this
yeah I mean the question was where do we
plan to go beyond food delivery when for
us the when we started or - it was
always you know like I said about you
know helping small business owners and
figuring out you know how do you serve
this for any local merchants whether
you're a macaroon store a restaurant or
a furniture shop I mean I that's still
our focus that's like the long-term
vision for now we're just focused on
restaurant delivery as a way to scale
but ultimately that's where you want to
end up in alright thank you guys for
having me my name is Walker I'm the CEO
and founder of teespring for those of
you guys who don't know what teespring
is we're an e-commerce platform that
allows entrepreneurs to launch products
and apparel brands without risk cost or
compromise today the company is about
180 folks and we ship tens of thousands
of products each day and I want to talk
to you about one of the most fundamental
advantages you have as a startup and
that's that you're able to do things
that don't scale and I define things
that don't scale as things that are sort
of fundamentally unsustainable they will
not last they will not bring in the
millionth user and where they break it's
usually time but it could be a number of
other things but it's really growth
strategies that won't take you to a
million users and there's three real
places I want to focus on today the
first one is finding your first users
the second one is turning those users
into champions and the third one is
finding your product and market fit so
finding your first users the first thing
you have to understand is that there is
no silver bullet
for user acquisition you know everybody
and this includes me when we got started
you look for that that dream solution
that pay-per-click campaign that has
tremendous ROI some accelerating
partnership that's gonna springboard you
into the stratosphere an affiliate
agreement something that solves it for
you but the reality is for the vast
majority of companies and in fact for
every company that I've had the chance
to speak to the CEO of that's just not
possible
those are unicorns and most of the
companies that from the outside it
looked like they've had this dream
growth curve the reality is that those
first users were impossibly hard to get
and let me tell you about the story of a
ridiculously unsustainable business so
this is teespring in 2012 when we first
got when we first launched the the
business couldn't have looked worse it
took days of meetings we had to offer
free design days of revisions back and
forth we'd have to launch the product
ourselves we'd have to do the social
media all to sell like 50 shirts for a
local nonprofit and generate a thousand
dollars of revenue anybody looking in
would have said you guys need to give up
this is a terrible idea
but as time went on those users start to
add up and you know I think something
you have to understand is that when you
first launch a company just by virtue of
the fact that it's a new product you're
gonna be bad at selling it right you've
got no idea what the pain points of
customers really are you've never sold
it before you don't have any success
stories to point to or testimonials
those first users are always going to be
the hardest and so it's your
responsibility as a founder to do
whatever it takes to bring in your first
users and you know it's gonna be
different for every company the common
thread that I hear is founders need to
spend personal time and effort a lot of
their personal time and effort to bring
those users in themselves it you know
can mean a number of things everything
from sending 100 emails a day getting on
the phone and just calling as many
people as you can going through a
network if you have a network like
Stanford or Y Combinator any
thing you can do to get that first user
and you know I really equate it to
pushing a boulder up a hill and if you
think of like a very sort of smooth Hill
the when you get started the incline is
the steepest and those first inches of
the hardest and over time as you get
farther and farther the incline studies
out it gets easier and hopefully
eventually you reach a point where
you're at the top of the hill and the
boulder starts to roll on its own and so
those first users you just cannot focus
on ROI in the sense of time do not
expect to spend an hour and return of
dollars maybe Stanley is one of those
unicorns that was a pretty incredible
story but for most of us
those first users are going to take a
lot of hand-holding a lot of personal
love and that's okay
that's essential for building a company
and the one sort of caveat of that is
that I don't recommend giving away your
product for free and there's plenty of
exceptions to this rule but in general
cutting costs or giving the product away
is an unsustainable strategy I wouldn't
recommend you need to make sure that
users value your product and you know
people have a different they treat
products that are free in a much
different way than a paid product and
often times it can give you a false
sense of security of oh we're getting
all these users surely we can convert
them over to paid the second aspect is
what happens when you get those users
how do you turn those users into
champions and a champion is a user who
talks about and advocates for your
product and I'm a firm believer that
every company with a great growth
strategy has users who are champions and
so really the easiest way to build turn
a user into a champion is to delight
them with an experience they're going to
remember so something that's unusual or
out of the ordinary an exceptional
experience and the easiest way to do
this early and again something that is
completely unsustainable it's not going
to scale forever is to just talk to
those users and people will say this all
the time and you hear it's one of the
sort of core tenants of Y Combinator is
talk to users but I
I cannot stress how important it is that
you spend a large chunk of your time
talking to users and you should do it
constantly every single day and as long
as possible today at teespring I'm still
the catch-all email address so anytime
somebody misspelled support or writes an
email address that doesn't exist
I get that email and so I still do about
12 to 20 customer service tickets every
single day I spent hours each night
reading every single tweet probably a
little bit OCD but that's okay I read
through all the teespring communities
you're never gonna get a better sense
for your product than actually listening
to real users and especially in the
early days you're just the products you
launch with and the feature set you
launch with is almost certainly not
going to be the feature set that you
scale with and the quicker you talk to
users and learn what they actually need
the faster you can get to that point so
there's three ways to talk to your
customers you can run customer service
yourself up until teespring was doing
about a hundred and thirty one hundred
forty thousand dollars a month my
co-founder Evan and I did everything in
customer service this is one that
there's going to be an instinct to
quickly pass off and that's because it's
painful even today when I open our
customer service portal I have like an
emotional reaction where my stomach
sinks because it sucks talking to users
who have had a terrible experience and
it's painful it's something that you
love and you've put so much effort into
and you've gotten it wrong or they've
had a terrible experience or somebody
didn't treat them right but it's so
important that you go through that and
learn what you need to build what you
need to fix the second step is to
proactively reach out to current and
current customers and insurance or
customers who have left and this is one
that that often falls by the wayside in
sort of the pursuit of new customers but
you want to make sure that your
customers are having a consistent good
experience you don't want to just leave
those current users as sort of you don't
want to take them for granted and then
when a user actually leaves your
servus you want to reach out and find
out why both because that personal
outreach can make the difference between
leaving and staying sometimes people
just need to know that you care and it's
going to get better and because even if
you can't bring them back there's a
chance that you can learn from the
mistake you made that caused them to
leave and fix it so you don't churn
users out the same way in the future and
the final one is again the one that I'm
probably too OCD about but it's social
media and communities you need to know
how people are talking about your brand
you need to reach out and make sure that
when somebody does have a bad experience
and they're talking about it that you
make it right problems are inevitable in
startups there's gonna be issues you're
not gonna have the perfect product
things are gonna break things are gonna
go wrong that's not important what's
important is to always make it right to
always go the extra mile and make that
customer happy one detractor who's had a
terrible experience on your platform is
enough to reverse the progress of ten
champions it's all it takes is one
person out there to say no you shouldn't
use those guys for x y&z reason to ruin
a ton of momentum so even if it's you
know there's examples in the early days
where we would mess up massive orders
we'd print the color slightly wrong it
would be the wrong size and it would be
like half of our gmv for that month and
we would know we got it wrong the
customer would be unhappy and sort of
this instinct is well you know it's it's
only a little bit off or it's not
completely wrong it'll be fine
but the reality is you just got to bite
the bullet and make sure that it's right
and those customers the customers that
are often originally the most frustrated
tend to turn into the biggest champions
and the longest term users and the last
one I want to talk about is finding
product and market fit and what I mean
by that is that you know I mentioned
this earlier but the product you launch
with will almost certainly not be the
product that takes you to scale and so
your job in those early moments in those
early days of a start-up is to progress
and iterate as
fast as possible to reach that product
that does have market fit and as
engineers your instinct is going to be
to build a platform with beautiful clean
code that scales right you don't want to
write a sort of duct-tape code that's
gonna pile on technical debt but you
need to optimize for speed over
scalability and clean code and sort of
an example of this is in the early days
we had a couple enterprise customers
coming to us sort of bigger nonprofits
and say hey we really like your service
but you're missing these fundamental
things so we can't we're not going to
use it and we looked at sort of what it
would take to build out those features
and we weren't sure they were gonna work
long term but we wanted to try it and my
co-founder Evan who is our CTO and a
million times better developer than I am
sort of ran the math and figured out
that if we did it the right way it was
gonna take about a month to build out
these features and in a startup
a month you know you live in dog years a
month is a year and that just wasn't
gonna do so he actually went out
duplicated the codebase duplicated the
the database and was able to basically
build a completely different product
that he didn't have to worry about the
existing users for to serve these
enterprise customers we gave them the
tool they on-boarded they generated a
lot of revenue eventually we learned
what features were core and we
integrated them into the core product
but what would have taken a month we
were able to do in you know three to
four days a great rule of thumb is to
only worry about the next order of
magnitude so when you have your tenth
user you shouldn't be wondering well how
are we gonna serve a million users you
should be worried about how are we gonna
get to a hundred when you're at a
hundred you should think about a
thousand it's it's one of those things
where necessity is the mother of
invention of all inventions so when you
hit that breaking point like the Twitter
fail whale is a great example and
teespring
there were months months stretches where
every single night the site would crash
every night and then during the day and
every single person on the team would go
to sleep with their phone on loud under
their pillow so that inevitably when the
buzzer went off we could quickly get up
restart the servers and go back to sleep
and this would happen daily but the
reality is that it was worth it and you
know you'll end up with these huge pain
points and all this for technical debt
and regret but it's worth it just to get
to that end goal and that product fit
faster you will make it work
you will survive Minh
bumps are just speed bumps and speed is
so so important early so the the lesson
that I've been learning lately is you
know you want to do these things that
don't scale as long as possible there's
not some magical moment it's not the
series a it's not when you hit a certain
revenue milestone that you stop doing
things that don't scale this is one of
your biggest advantages as a company and
the moment you give it up you're giving
your competitors that are smaller that
can still do these things that advantage
over you so as long as humanly possible
as long as it is a net positive you need
to be spending time talking to your
users you need to move fast and
development as fast as possible
but don't give it up willingly it should
be ripped from you and so sort of trying
to practice what I preach I want to give
you guys my email address if you guys
have any questions if you want to learn
about teespring if you want to print
some t-shirts
fingers crossed just shoot me an email
I'd love to help and I'd love to speak
to you and the last thing is we've
created an official how to start a
startup tea with Sam and all proceeds
are going to watse I couldn't miss this
opportunity to sell so if you guys want
to grab one of the official teas just go
to teespring comm slash startup and it's
supporting a great cause
thank you
sure go ahead the t-shirt printing
business do you think it has a lot of
combat so what made you what convinced
you to think this is a viable market
even when sure you know so the question
was the t-shirt printing business has a
lot of competition what would convince
us to get into the market I think
there's two factors to it so first I I
completely agree from the outside people
have been telling us that this is a
silly idea since day one and sort of at
every order of magnitude we reach people
will come and say hey that's a terrible
terrible idea why are you doing that but
the reason that we launched teespring is
because we ran into a personal pain
point where we had a need and we looked
at the current solutions I was a student
at Brown and I was trying to create a
remember the bar shirt for a dive bar
that got shut down and I realized that
nothing needed nothing matched my needs
and so because I knew that I had that
pain point and I knew there was market
fit and I had seen people adopt the
product I knew there was something there
and it was also one of those things
where you can sort of feel the you can
you can sort of feel the wind on your
back where people are adopting the
product quickly you're the pain point is
clearly there it's not a met need so I
would say that often times great ideas
start by looking like silly ideas and
then you can sort of feel out whether or
not there's a scalable business here by
how people are adopting it is it
possible to bring customers aboard sure
no you know today our biggest customer
base are entrepreneurs who are trying to
build brands and businesses you know we
have a little over a thousand people
that make their full time living on
teespring today via brands they've
launched and the other side is
influencers so YouTube stars reddit
communities bloggers who want to add
product merchandise as a way to sort of
create a brand and monetize that
affinity so those are our two biggest
markets we still do
work with a lot of nonprofits and love
working with them it's still a part of
our business just not the majority well
while I wait for the slide to happen I
started a bunch of startups but I think
you've heard a lot of awesome you know
kind of how did I get started stories so
I'm gonna talk about something very
specific that people always have
questions with which is press and like
how do you get it how does it work it's
something this is kind of like an
abridged version of what we talked about
at Y Combinator and hopefully you guys
will find it helpful so you know a lot
of people I think when they first get
started with entrepreneurship think
about getting press and being in the
press is something that happens
magically they think about it as like
something that you know journalists are
like out there like trying to find the
best stories and really you know
discover them like it's like a
meritocracy which is like absolutely not
the case so before you think about press
one of the things you really want to
think about is who you want to reach and
like what's your actual goal right a lot
of people like I know when I got started
I wanted to just be in the news because
I thought that's what like he did as an
important company and it turns out it if
you don't have any goals
you're not gonna achieve them right I
mean that's true of like pretty much
everything and with press if you just
like aimlessly want to be covered it's
not really going to do anything for your
startup so getting like in the news it's
nice because you can send it to your mom
or and say hey I have a real job you
know look we're in the New York Times
but if you don't have a actual goal for
you're like a business goal with it it's
really just like not a good use of time
so you know there's many different goals
one example is you know you might want
to with with social cam which was a
spinoff of justin.tv it was like an app
that was kind of like video Instagram
and our goal was really to be known as
like a video like in
the Graham app and like be thought of in
that context when it was you know time
to pitch our like Silicon Valley
investors and and influencers and so we
really wanted to get in like tech press
and kind of be positioned as this like
new hot social app with exec one of my
goals was ii like to get customers so
exec was like a cleaning local cleaning
service and our goal was to get people
in San Francisco to use it it wasn't
like useful to get national press
because you know 99% of those people
couldn't use it so we really targeted
initially a lot of you know like SF
Chronicle and a like local San Francisco
press that would directly talk to people
who could potentially use our app for
twitch which is probably the thing that
you guys mostly know it was you know
twitch was a ESPN for gaming or kind of
like a live streaming community of
gamers and our goal was to with press
was like to reach the gaming industry
cuz like when we when we started now
it's like 55 million uniques and like
people in the gaming industry know about
it but when we started nobody really
knew that like it was a place to
advertise and like it wasn't like known
as like a you know we were very nascent
small gaming community and our goal was
to like get people in the gaming
industry whether they were developers or
advertisers to think about us as like an
important place where like influencers
were so we really targeted you know
industry trades and game dev blogs and
places where like gamers when they up
games beat stuff like that the industry
was reading so you know what's an actual
story I think there's you know there's a
bunch of different types of stories but
these are usually the ones that you see
in you know startups
those are like product launches like you
let just launched a new version of your
app there's fundraising for whatever
reason you know press loves to write
about fundraising even though it's not
very interesting so you know like if you
raise a million dollars you drown
pretty much you can get that covered
milestones or metrics like you've
achieved a million dollars a week in
revenue that one of our one of our the
the company that bought exact just
announced that they they achieved a
million dollars a week in revenue and it
was covered pretty widely like business
stories which generally happen when
you're like already a successful company
someone you might go New York Times or
New Yorker business magazine will like
want to cover like kind of the story of
your startup usually don't have to worry
about that in the beginning what I like
to call stunts which are like I know if
you guys remember but a couple years ago
this YC company called WePay dropped a
block of ice with money frozen in it
outside of the paypal like a PayPal
Developers Conference because they were
like PayPal was like no in the news for
freezing
you know like various developers
accounts and so that was like they're
widely covered because it was just so
you know kind of an interesting thing
and it really it got them in this story
right they wouldn't been talked about in
the context of PayPal at all really
hiring announcement if you're a big
enough company and you hire someone
really important people want to cover
that and then contributed articles like
you writing some sort of industry
overview or some opinion piece in like
maybe a tech blog or site like that so
those are like you know basically any of
those things can can be stories one of
the things that people usually don't
think about is that you know you really
have to think about like everything when
you start a start-up you think that
everything you're doing is interesting
but that's not true for like other
people right like dude you what you need
really need to think about it's like
objectively if I wasn't the founder of
this company would I want to like read a
story about what I'm pitching right so
you know you're incremental feature
release or 2.01 you know feature release
might not be interesting it like just
because you add it like you know find
your contacts in the facebook or
something like you have to you really
want to take a step back before you
invest the time and like actually trying
to pitch a story and think does anyone
will anyone actually want to read this
because what people are you know
journalists and bloggers are looking for
is things that people actually want to
read right the other thing is like you
don't actually have to be very original
your press in news doesn't have to be
original you know like you don't you
just have to be like what I like to call
original enough right so you don't want
to be the second cooler company to raise
five million dollars on Kickstarter
right that's like that the first guy
gets like all the news but like if
you're the
I think the first video game console to
raise ten million dollars on Kickstarter
like ooh yah was that was like really
raised like a million dollars in in 24
hours that was like huge news because
they were kind of like the first in that
category right even though other people
had raised a lot of money on Kickstarter
before so just like think about your
stories in the context of like where
they are in the like what else has been
written about and if they're like kind
of novel enough and they haven't been
something that was like just written
about in the news
so one of them like actual mechanics of
getting a story this is like pretty
tactical so what if you want to get your
news in you know the the press basically
there's some easy simple steps so it's
basically getting press is like you can
think of it like a sales funnel so
you're gonna talk to a lot of people and
not all of them are gonna convert right
and so you shouldn't be upset when
someone like one individual person or a
reporter or whatever it doesn't write
your story the first thing is like you
have to think of a story right it's
gonna be one of those probably one of
those things that I listed up before the
second step is like you want to get
introduced to a reporter or multiple
reporters who are gonna write about your
thing
it's like much much easier just like any
sort of business development to actually
get in touch with them through someone
it's like you know rather than cold
emailing them the best thing to do I
found is like you want to go to
entrepreneurs who were just written
about like your friends who maybe
started to startup and they were covered
on TechCrunch get them to introduce you
to your that reporter who wrote about
them the reason that's good is because
like from the entrepreneurs perspective
like the easiest thing to do in the
world is introduce you to a reporter who
already wrote about them right they
don't like need anything else from that
reporter they're actually doing that
person a favor if your story's
interesting it's not like you're asking
for interest to investors or potential
you know people that they would want to
hire employees and then from the
reporter's perspective they're getting
intro to someone who you know they
already vetted as interesting like
they're getting an answer from someone
who they know they thought was
interesting enough to write about and so
like by the transitive property you're
basically gonna they're gonna think
you know probably interesting so you get
like an email that's like oh you know
from this guy that introduces you to the
reporter and you want to get in contact
with them with enough time that you can
actually get them to like write a story
probably a week in advance or more
because they're not gonna like drop
everything they're doing to just write
about your news so a lot of people
especially first-time entrepreneurs will
come and say like just that I'm
launching this product tomorrow like can
you get me in this you know TechCrunch
or something and that's like probably
not gonna happen unless you already have
a relationship the best way to do it so
the best thing to do is like give
yourself some lead time get that intro
in advance and then so then you should
like once once you've set a date for
your news to go out you're gonna launch
your product like in two weeks you have
this intro you set up some sort of
meeting and you really want to get the
the reporter to like invest time and
effort in you because they don't like
there's like kind of a sunk cost fallacy
at play basically if you the more time
and then they spend with you the more
likely they are to like actually write
something so you the best thing to do is
get like a face-to-face meeting right
lots of people report bloggers actively
don't want to meet you face-to-face but
like if not that then get like a phone
call right and get on the phone with
them the worst thing to do is like just
have an email exchange right because
it's very easy for them to like forget
about it ignore it so you want to like
actually try to get in contact with them
instead of a meeting okay so then the
next step is actually pitch them what I
usually do is actually write out all my
new like this story that I would want to
see published like in bullet points and
I like will write out the store Mike my
ideal story and I'll memorize it like
the entire like set of bullet points and
when I have a conversation with them if
it's in person I'll like walk them
through this like I'll have a
conversation that's like structured like
my outline and they'll be like taking
notes right and then they'll go and
transcribe those notes into a story and
so it's like a tell like what I wrote
will eventually be translated into a
actual story and you know by preparing
you can actually canoe
much more easily control the
conversation and not forget critical
things like you know your co-founding
your co-founders name or like what the
fall the features in your awesome app
are if it's I'm doing this like on the
phone I will like have this bullet
points in front of me and I will make
sure to like walk through a conversation
that includes all of those things so you
know you do that they you have a pitch
to take they take notes they're gonna
write the story at this time and then
the next thing is like follow up like a
couple days or a day before your actual
news goes out you want to send them an
email that says like you know this is
the time we're launching the app like
just thanks for meeting here's like
collateral like media if you have like a
video or photos or something you want
them to include screenshots like how to
spell your co-founders names and your
name just like include all the
information that I really care about and
I bowled it right and then that's it
then hopefully the the day comes you
press submit on their release to the App
Store and at the same time they release
their article on TechCrunch and you are
famous okay so a lot of people ask us
about PR firms so you know I think in
the beginning it's kind of like
everything else you do at a start-up you
want to do it yourself before you hire
someone else to do it and yeah it's
actually pretty easy especially with
tech press who you know and bloggers who
like constantly need new things to write
about and you know you should I strongly
encourage people to like try it
themselves and kind of get started by
learning the process themselves before
they hire anyone one thing I'll say is
that like firms can't can only help you
with like kind of the contacts and the
logistics but they can't help you
know what's interesting about your
company or very you know I've never had
anyone who's been able to tell me what
the stories that I'm producing are
they've only been able to tell me you
know like you're you know like here's
other here's a list of reporters that
you might want to contact so you know
you really have to be responsible for
thinking about like what's interesting
about your company of what are you doing
you know what's the roadmap of
interesting things that you're working
on they're also really expensive you
know I think we were spending between
five thousand and twenty thousand
dollars a month which is like
at very you know for various firms
that's a lot for a start-up right you
should it's generally not a good use of
money I would say especially in their
very early days you know getting press
is a lot of work so you should really
make sure it's worth it
you know like I said it really getting
press doesn't mean it feels like it's
like a vanity metric right it feels like
you're being successful because lots of
successful companies you know like
Google and Facebook are covered in the
press all the time but it doesn't
actually mean you're successful it
doesn't you know actually give you you
know mean that you're getting you're
making money you're getting users you're
making their disease you're happy it's
you know sometimes it's a really good
strategy for getting your first hundred
or two hundred or a thousand customers
but it's really not a scalable user
acquisition strategy so it's something
that's really just like a you know
bootstrap you can't like just get like
infinity articles written about you like
eventually people are going to like get
tired of hearing about your company and
usually that happens pretty pretty
quickly right look the pull point about
news is it's new and so it's pretty
pretty pretty hard
unless you're Google to like get covered
in the press like every week you know
something to you know if you decide it's
worth it though like they do want to
have like a regular heartbeat of news so
that's like something where you know
you're planning out those types of that
what you're thinking about what you're
doing that matches those you know maybe
seven story types in the future and like
you know when I was you know working
primarily on marketing and PR it would
be I would like make a schedule on like
a calendar if what when we're gonna
launch things and like make sure to
space them out but like have them you
know appear regularly at regular
intervals so that people like didn't
wouldn't forget about us and we could
kind of maximize our coverage and you
don't really want to keep your you know
contacts fresh it's like really a
relationships business so once you
someone writes about you should keep
going back to them for form or for
writing about you know to write about
you in the future it's kind of like you
know when when basically people you know
you're more likely that do something for
someone you've already liked it done
something for you know you really like
it's if you just you know I would try to
establish good good relationships with a
couple reporters over time that you can
go to to you know break news and it will
come in
handy later if you ever have are in the
position if you're fortunate enough to
be in the position where people are
writing negative things about you you
know having relationships will help you
you know kind of get your side of the
story out and the last thing is like you
know it's kind of a golden rule really
or maybe more like a pay it forward
really applies here like you should help
your fellow entrepreneurs get get
coverage because they will help you get
coverage the best way to get covered is
really through these like warm
introductions and so you know when I'm
ever I'm you know meeting with reporters
I always help like throwing out the
names of like other things that I think
would be interesting stories for them
and usually that comes back they know
the reporters like it because they it's
like helping them find interesting
stories and you're more likely to get
you know leads back from those
entrepreneurs than you help out so if
you're interested in learning more about
press there's two resources that I
really liked Jason Kincaid it was former
TechCrunch reporter just wrote a really
really great overview that covers a lot
of things I just talked about in more
depth and from the you know blogger side
that was a really great book and then
kind of an evil resource is this book
trust me I'm lying which was written by
and the one of the former marketer at
American Apparel and he talks about like
a lot of ways that he pretty like evilly
actually manipulated the press but I
think it's a pretty good look into like
the psychology of like how people you
know things spread on the internet you
know how stories spread on the Internet
and I it's it's um might be valuable to
take a look at cool that's that's
basically it
one question just one to quit okay two
questions or zero questions when is the
right time to start worrying about press
all together I think it's a really good
way like if you just the first time I
launched you know my first products in
our in our first startup for a lot of
them we got like zero attention and we
didn't really know how to even get a
hundred users I think it's a really fine
way to get a hundred users and a lot of
companies in YC when they first launched
their product will encourage them to get
out and just do one tech Mart story to
like get a few people to see it and it's
good to get in the practice I wouldn't
like obsess over getting like coverage
in multiple outlets or anything like
that in the be very beginning I had
anything else so twitch you know had
this thing called twitchplayspokemon
where a developers set up like a Pokemon
like Gameboy game that was controlled by
chat so you know millions of people
would be typing in a or b and like the
character would run around aimlessly and
that was like a huge news story and I
think that what we did was you know
there's a couple of parts when we set
the stage by having other news stories
that so when someone from the BBC would
Google like twitch and be like what is
this crazy thing that everyone I rented
is talking about they would like have
some contact the other thing is like we
didn't come up with the idea for Twitter
right that was like fortuitous but we
helped you like give it legs by you know
making the company available to talk to
the reporters and suggesting follow up
stories about like you know there were
stories not just about
twitchplayspokemon because a hundred
thousand people were watching this
Pokemon game but because you know if
finally like there were stories when
they beat the game and there were
stories when they launched twitch plays
Pokemon you know crystal or whatever the
next Pokemon version wasn't like so he
kind of gave that story like a little
bit more legs but we didn't you know
originated it it was the community
really whoo-hoo
they did it alright I think that's it
thank you very much
[Applause]
you